the quick bird to satellite flies high
over the Pacific and captures these
images of gigantic square blocks off a
remote island in the region known as
Micronesia with something strange going
on on the coast of the Micronesian
Island of Panipat there are these tiny
islands almost a hundred of them that
are remarkably similar and geometrically
shaped the reason it's not so clear
where did they come from what why were
they created there are all kinds of
taboos about visiting the place why here
why off the coast as the satellite image
indicates Hana pay is extremely remote
2,500 miles from Los Angeles and 1,600
miles from Australia once it was
inhabited by an ancient race about whom
very little is known why would somebody
build a city out in the middle of the
ocean
why here so far away from any other
known civilization the 97 individual
blocks seen in the satellite image are
separated by narrow channels of water
it's not until these are seen at ground
level that the extraordinary shape and
scale of these structures become so
striking as amazing as this site appears
from satellite imagery coming down to
ground level it's even more astounding
there are walls that are 25 feet tall
and 17 feet thick the local name only
adds to the mystery the name nan Madol
means the space in between and there are
numerous canals that run and separate
these tiny islets so it's a reference to
that but at the same time nan Madol has
a history of reports of being haunted
some people even call it the ghosts in